la très célèbre tour de New York lampai
State Building qui désormais le plus
haut building de la ville a été rouvert
hier au public qui est venu en nbre
malgré tout mais la tour a été très vite
fermée dès l'après-midi en raison
d'alerte à la bombe Yasmina Farber
l'observatoire de l'Empire State
Building offre l'une des plus belles
vues de New York cet immeuble symbole de
la ville est toujours debout un lieu
culte pour les visiteurs pour patienter
dans la file d'attente une bande annonce
aujourd'hui dépassé
de voir les tours
jumelles côté sud le skyline le panorama
de la New York d'aujourd'hui si
l'horizon est définitivement différent
les réflex touristi n'ont pas
changé j'espère que cela ne va pas
devenir une attraction pour les
touristes je le souhaite vraiment vous
aimeriez que l'on reconstruise les
tn non
non il faudrait plutôt un
mémorial au 86e étage il y a aussi tout
ceux qui restent sous le choc ils
habitent Manan la banlieu comme ce
couple qui vient de Long Island pour eu
ce n'est pas du voyurisme c'est un peu
comme une
thérapie venir ici r les choses plus
réell quand on voit les imag à la
télévision les photos dans les journaux
cemble toujours
FM s passé ailleurs dans un autre
pays de voir tout cela ici et maintenant
on réalise que c'est la
réalité même cette équipe de pompiers du
Massachusets qui a travaillé dans la
zone du World Trade a eu besoin de
prendre de la hauteur quelques jours
après le drame la fréquentation est
habituelle on refuse de céder à la
psychose de
l'attentat je crois qu'en France ils
sont beaucoup plus inquiets que
nous mais Mo je honnêtement je réalise
pas après une alerte à la bombe l'Empire
State a fermé son observatoire il
rouvrira lundi matin pour les uns
l'Empire State Building faisait partie
d'un circuit touristique bien ordinaire
les autres avaient besoin de quitter
leur petit écran de voir en grand ce
nouvel horizon cette carte postale qui
leur brise le
cœur